The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome
back, everybody to 8.03.
Very happy to see you again.
So as you can see
from the slides,
we will continue the
discussion from last time.
We were talking about
interference phenomena,
which involve two or
multiple point light source.
And they actually
interact with each other
and produce interesting
phenomenon, which
we see with laser,
with water ripples,
and also we discussed how to
design a phased radar together.
And one thing which we learned
is that if you, for example,
have two slit interference, OK.
And if you look at the intensity
of the resulting interference
pattern as a function
of angle, you
will see that there are
peaks, periodic peaks
as a function of angle.
And we also know
how to calculate
where would be the
principal maxima, what
would be the minima,
which will have
destructive interference between
the two point light source.
OK?
So as usual, we go from
one electromagnetic wave
to two electromagnetic waves
and two unelectromagnetic waves.
And today we are going
to do infinite number
of electromagnetic
waves and they
are going to interact
with each other
or superpose an infinite
number of electromagnetic waves
all together.
And that brings us to that
discussion of diffraction.
OK?
So what are we going
to talk about today is,
for example, a point light
source, a laser pointer.
And what would the image of
a laser pointer look like?
When these lasers pass through
a single slit or just the laser
itself.
The laser beam itself, what
will happen to this laser beam?
And also we will make some
comments on the Star Trek,
for example.
Right?
They have this super weapon
which they shoot enemy
with this laser beam.
And we'll see how practical that
is by the end of this course.
And the third thing is that
it's related to resolution.
So we are going to
design a phone, screen
of your mobile phone together to
see what is actually practical,
what is actually not practical.
If Yen-Jie is opening a new
company to develop jPhone,
what should be the requirement
for the screen, for example?
Which, I'm not going to do it.
So this is actually what we
are going to discuss today.
So we are interested
in a situation where
you have plane waves, and those
plane waves are approaching
from the left-hand side of the
screen toward a single slit.
So basically, the
setup is like this.
So you have those
wavefront basically
is traveling to the right-hand
side, the plane waves.
And on the wall, there's a
slit or hole, which is actually
a opening, and the
waves can actually
penetrate through this hole.
The width of this hole is
denoted by, or essentially
given to you, which
is actually D.
And we were wondering what
is going to happen to--
what are we going to observe on
the screen, which is actually
pretty far away from the wall.
And this screen is
actually used to observe
the pattern of the
interference pattern
of the electromagnetic
wave passing this hole.
So, as we discussed last time,
due to Huygens' principle,
every point is actually
like a point-like source
of spherical waves.
So, as you can see
now, we actually
consider the size of our slit.
Therefore, there must be a lot
of point-like source inside,
in this slit.
When this wavefront actually
pass through this wall,
there should be infinite
number of point-like source.
And all of them, due
to Huygens' principle,
is going to be like point-like
source of spherical waves.
And they are all emitting from
all those possible location,
and that they are
overlapping each other
and they have constructive
or destructive interference
with each other.
So that is actually
what is happening
with this single-slit
experiment.
And we call that diffraction.
So you may be wondering, why
do I call it diffraction?
Why not interference?
Because it's basically the
same phenomenon, right?
I think it's just a
matter of wording.
Feynman actually
commented on this,
and he said that, nobody
was able to define
the difference between
diffraction and interference
in a satisfactory way.
Which is actually true.
So it's just a
matter of wording.
So we are looking at exactly the
same phenomena when we actually
discuss this experiment.
So what I am going
to do today is now
to introduce to you the
way we can deal with this.
I'm sure you have seen this
experiment before, maybe
in 8.02 or in high school days.
On the other hand, what
we are going to do today
is to really make use
of the mathematics which
we have learned from 18.03
or from the previous lectures
to attack this problem.
So what is actually
the mathematics
I am going to use today?
So the mathematics
which I would like
to use to attack this
problem is to use
a two-dimensional
Fourier transform.
I think by now you should
not be afraid of Fourier
transform any more.
It should be pretty natural.
It's just integration,
and you evaluate, and then
you are going to get
the corresponding number
whatsoever.
But the cool thing is
that 18.03 give them
physical meaning
of those numbers,
and I'm going to
talk about that.
So what is actually the Fourier
transform I'm going to use?
So I am going to
evaluate C, which
is a function of kx and ky.
And what is actually
this C function?
This C function is equal to
1 over 4 pi squared, which
I really don't care too much.
It's just a constant.
And I do the integration
from minus infinity
to infinity for dx, and I do a
integration from minus infinity
to infinity dy, a
small letter scale, dy.
And I have a f function,
which I will introduce you
what the f function mean, what
does the f function actually
represent.
And exponential minus i, k is
the vector which is actually
telling you the direction
of the propagation
of the spherical wave,
times r, which is actually
a function of x and y.
And this is actually
the kind of integration
which we will employ in order
to attack the problem we
are interested in this lecture.
So, what does this
integration mean?
So we have basically some kind
of this two-dimensional Fourier
transform.
The f function is
actually telling you
the shape of the source.
So basically, this is
actually telling you
about the shape of the source.
As we discussed
before, the shape
of the source, every
point on this shape
is a source of spherical
wave, by Huygens' principle.
So that is actually
telling you where should I
do the integration.
This one, exponential i
k dot r, what is that?
This is actually telling you
about the spherical wave.
So remember, we were doing
two-slit interference before,
and we have actually two
exponential function, if you
remember from last lecture.
So now, this is
actually put there
because each source
you are going
to get exponential
function, which is actually
presenting the propagation
of the electromagnetic wave.
You can say that,
oh, wait, wait, wait.
The omega t disappeared, right?
There's no omega t here, right?
But I don't really care
because everybody is actually
oscillating at the same
frequency, the same phase.
Therefore, I factorize out.
After I have done
all the calculation,
I can multiply the whole thing
by cosine omega t, and probably
some phi.
Then that is actually modulating
and oscillating up and down
as the plane wave, as
you approach the wall.
So, therefore, I actually
already factorize it out.
So this is actually telling
you about the electric field.
And what is actually here?
This is actually the
unit area you are
performing this integration.
And you can actually
do integration
over the full universe.
So you have a plane
which actually extend
to the whole full universe.
But what is actually
really contributing
is defined by this f
function, which is actually
the shape of the source.
And some normalization
factor, which I don't really
care too much.
So this looks really fancy,
but is actually not that fancy.
And what product you are
getting here is our C function,
is that C is actually a
function of kx and ky.
What is kx and ky?
It's actually telling you
the direction of propagation.
The k vector is actually
telling you the direction
of the propagation.
If you evaluate C with a
specific given kx and ky,
basically you are evaluating
the total electric field
going some direction, which is
actually defined by kx and ky.
So the big picture
is the following.
So basically you
have some source.
It can look like
this in the xy plane.
This is x and y plane.
All those things,
all those points,
all those little
areas inside this hole
is spherical wave source.
And the f function actually
define the shape of this hole.
And this integration is
actually integrating over
all those little areas.
And then calculate
the contribution
from each small area,
sum them together.
Then, finally, you are getting
something which is actually
a function of kx and ky.
What is kx and ky?
It's actually giving you
the direction of propagation
from this point-like
source to observer P.
And this C function is
actually proportional
to the total electric field.
So you can see that,
hah, we have learned
this Fourier transform
from the math department,
and we give life
to this function.
Now actually we understand
what we are doing now.
We are actually really
summing all over the,
summing over the available
point-like source.
And add all the contribution
of the electromagnetic wave
together.
Then what we are
getting, the C function
is actually proportional to
the total electric field.
So that is actually
the big picture.
Any questions so far?
I hope you can actually
understand what we are doing.
So now what I am going to do
is to really use this formula
and attack the problem
which we are actually
trying to understand,
the single-slit problem.
So suppose I have a single
slit which looks like this.
I'm zooming in this thing
maybe 100 times, 1,000 times.
And this is actually a wall.
It's very, very long.
I would like to define
first my coordinate system.
The x direction, as I
actually drew from there,
is actually pointing upward.
The y direction is actually
parallel to the wall.
And the z direction
is actually going
to where the screen
which I am trying
to display the outcome
of this experiment.
And the distance
between these two walls
is actually D, which is
actually given there.
So I would like to
actually understand
what is going to happen when
the plane waves pass through
with this single slit.
Therefore, before I calculate
the C function proportional
to the total electric
field, what I really need
is a functional form, f, which
describe this single slit.
And just to make sure that
everybody is on the same page,
this wall is actually infinitely
long, from minus infinity in y
to positive infinity y.
So it's actually
a super long wall.
And these two edge is
actually-- the distance
between the edges is actually D.
So what would be the f
function which describes
the shape of the light source?
f function is a
function of x and y.
And I define a f
function, and I give you
this function to describe
the experimental setup.
So the f function can be
either 1, which actually shows
that there are
point-like source there,
or 0 when I am talking
about things on the wall,
because there's no
point-like source there.
Because the wall is
actually blocking the light.
So it can be either 1 or 0.
When is that equal to 1?
When minus D over 2.
If I define-- this is
actually x equal to 0.
The middle of the slit
is actually x equal to 0.
Then it is actually equal
to 1 when minus D over 2
smaller than or equal to x,
smaller or equal to D over 2.
So that will give you a slit
with width of capital D.
On the other hand, if
the absolute value of x
is greater than D
over 2, then I get 0.
So now you can see
that is actually
the meaning of f function.
f function is
actually giving you
a map of the point-like source.
And what I am going to do now
is to really do the integration
to sum over all the spherical
electromagnetic waves coming
from all those
point-like source,
and to calculate the
total electric field.
So now I can go ahead and
calculate C function, which
is actually a function
of kx and ky, related
to the direction of
propagation, or, say,
the relative position
of the observer
and the overall
point-like source.
And this is actually equal
to 1 over 4 pi squared,
according to my formula.
And now I'm going to do an
integration from minus infinity
to infinity.
But I found that there's
a shortcut I can take.
f x y is only nonzero between
minus D over 2 and plus
D over 2 in the x direction.
Therefore, this integration
becomes integration
from minus D over 2 to
positive D over 2 dx,
exponential minus i kx times x.
I'm taking part of the k vector
dot r out of this formula.
The relevant part related
to x direction integration
is exponential i kx times x.
And now I can actually do the
integration in the y direction.
So you can see that,
in the y direction,
this slit is infinity
long, covering
the from the left-hand
side edge of the universe
to the right-hand side
edge of the universe.
Really long.
Super long.
Minus infinity to infinity
in the y direction.
The relevant part of
the exponential minus k
dot r is exponential
minus i ky times y.
So, before I do
this integration,
I would like to remind you
one thing which is actually
we have learned from the
past, from the help of math
department.
So we know delta function
x minus a is actually equal
to 1 over 2 pi, integration
from minus infinity to infinity,
exponential i p x minus a dp.
So we know about this formula.
So that means I can easily
evaluate this function.
So this function, I'm actually
doing the integration over y.
Therefore, what I'm
going to get is,
I take 1 over 2 pi out of this.
I take 2 pi out of this.
Then, basically, I
can actually arrive
expression, which is
actually delta function
is a function of ky.
After you do this integration
using this formula here.
So p here is actually y in
my integration I'm doing.
And what I'm going
to get is actually
ky equal to 0, minus
0, and I simplify
that to be delta function of ky.
So basically, you
are going to get
the ky contribution is going
to give you a delta function.
So how about the
integration which
is the other part
of the integration?
The other part of
the integration
is related to x
direction, is here.
So, basically, what
is actually left over?
I took already 1
over 2 pi from here.
Therefore, I have 1 over 2
pi, and I do the integration.
It's just a
exponential function.
I'm not super worried.
Basically, I get
1 over minus i kx.
Exponential minus i kx x.
And evaluated at D over
2, x equal to D over 2,
and x equal to minus D over 2.
I hope this part is
straightforward enough.
Any questions so far?
Everybody's following?
All right.
Very good.
So I will continue the red part.
So I will just look
at the red part
and then continue on this board.
I'm using the red pen, right.
So, basically, what
I am going to get
is, basically you have 1
over 2 pi, 1 over minus i kx,
exponential minus i kx D over
2, minus exponential i kx D
over 2.
So the red part of the
left function become this.
And you can actually
easily realize
that this is
actually proportional
to a sine function, right?
So basically I'm going to get
1 over 2 pi minus 2i sine kx
D over 2, divided by i kx.
This is actually
coming from there.
And this is actually
coming from-- this minus
2i sine function is coming
from the exponential function
I can cancel this
2, and basically I
get 1 over pi kx sine
kx D divided by 2.
So if I put everything
together, so basically
what you are getting is delta
function of ky, 1 over pi kx
sine kx D over 2.
Am I going too fast?
Everybody is following?
So I hope this mathematics
is straightforward enough.
And don't forget
what we are doing.
So what we are doing
is the following.
So we have this two-dimensional
Fourier transform.
And the goal is to sum
over all the waves coming
from a shape defined
by f function.
And I'm going to
evaluate the C function,
and the C function
is proportional
to the total electric field.
C is a function of kx and ky.
kx and ky give you
the information
about the direction,
relative position
of the source and the observer
P. And from this exercise,
what we actually
learn from here is
that the C function
is a function of y,
but essentially only nonzero
when ky is equal to what?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0, right?
Does that surprise you?
No, probably not.
Why is that?
Why should we expect that?
Because in the y direction
this slit is infinitely long.
So if you have contribution
of many, many spherical wave,
and this slit is
infinity long, the sum
of all those spherical
wave is going
to be still like a wavefront.
You can do this in your head.
So that means the direction,
if I choose a direction which
is actually pointing to
somewhere which is actually
with a ky not equal to 0--
so that means I have
a specific direction--
what I'm going to get is
that the electric field,
the total electric field,
will be equal to 0.
And, of course, you
can actually also
talk about what will
happen in the x direction.
So that is actually the
dependence of the C function
to the kx.
And we found
interesting dependence.
It's actually sine kx
D over 2 divided by kx.
So what I'm going to do is to
make our life slightly easier
by defining something which is
actually easier to understand.
But before that, I
would like to say
that the electric field,
as I mentioned before,
is going to be proportional
to the C function.
And now I would like to
drop the y direction,
because it's just
a delta function.
Therefore, I can actually
drop it in the discussion.
Then I will say that
this electric field
is going to be proportional to
the sine kx D over 2, divided
by kx.
Since we have the
electric field,
the magnitude of
the electric field,
then I can actually calculate
what will be the intensity.
Intensity is actually
what we care.
It's going to be
proportional to E square,
and that is actually
proportional to C square.
And what is actually that value?
That is going to be proportional
to sine square kx D divided
by 2, divided by kx squared.
Any questions so far?
So remember what is
actually we are discussing.
So we are discussing
about a single slit,
and we were wondering what
will happen to observer point P
when they actually do get,
when these observer do get
the interference pattern of
all the point-like source
between these two walls.
We can actually make it
much more understandable
by using angle,
which is actually
theta, which is
the measure of AP,
which is the direction of the--
which is a vector connecting
the slit to the observer--
to the horizontal direction.
And I can define the
displacement with respect
to the center to be x.
And I can actually
also express AP
by a vector which is r vector.
Basically, after
this definition,
we can actually calculate
or express sine theta.
Since the distance between
the screen and the wall
is very, very large, therefore
the theta angle is very small.
Therefore, I can safely assume
that sine theta is actually
x divided by r.
And also, at the same
time, this is actually
equal to kx divided by k.
Because the k vector
is actually telling you
the direction of propagation.
So, therefore, I can
actually rewrite this.
This will become kx.
The magnitude of k
vector is actually
basically 2 pi over lambda.
So, therefore, you can
actually calculate that,
and you will get kx times
lambda divided by 2 pi.
Therefore, the goal
is to rewrite kx
in a form which we
understand, which is theta.
So now we have achieved that.
What is actually kx?
kx is actually equal to 2 pi
sine theta divided by lambda.
And this means that
my intensity, which
I appended there, will be
proportional to sine square pi
D divided by lambda sine
theta, divided by 2 pi sine
theta divided by
lambda, squared.
So basically what I'm doing
is to replace kx and then
write it in terms of theta.
If I define beta to be
equal to pi D sine theta
over lambda, if I define
this, basically you
are getting sine
square beta, this
will be proportional to
sine squared beta divided
by beta squared.
And this beta is actually
proportional to theta and D.
Any questions so far?
I'm just doing a replace, I'm
just replacing the variables
so that it's actually
in terms of theta
and in terms of some variable
which actually simplify
the expression dramatically.
So, that's very good.
So we have actually
evaluated the intensity,
the resulting intensity which
will show up on the screen.
And then we found
that essentially
proportional to sine square pi
D divided by lambda sine theta,
divided by something squared.
And then I called
this constant, sorry,
I called this expression,
I defined this expression
to be beta.
Then the functional form
become much simpler.
It's become sine square
beta divided by beta square.
So what I am going to do now
is to visualize this result.
So what I'm trying to do
now is to plot the intensity
I as a function of sine
theta, for example, using
this expression.
So what I'm going to get is
something which is actually
going to be decreasing.
Something is going
to be decreasing
as a function of beta.
So that's the dashed line.
This dashed line is
actually proportional to 1
over beta squared.
And sine theta very
small, you actually
reach a maximum value of I0.
When you move away
from theta equal to 0,
you actually will hit a
minimum when the sine theta
is equal to lambda over D.
Because if sine theta is
equal to lambda over D, then
this expression become what?
Become what value when
sine theta is actually
lambda over D?
Pi.
Sine pi is 0, right?
Therefore, you have a
destructive interference.
This point is
really interesting.
Why?
Because that means all
the point-like source,
all of them between
these two walls,
are working together so nicely
such that the total field is
completely cancelled.
Isn't that remarkable?
That's really, really
crazy when this happens.
Takes a lot of work, infinite
number of source, to do that.
Then, if you actually increase
further the sine theta,
move away from the
center of the screen,
basically you see that this
will increase again and reach
a smaller maxima,
and again reach 0
when this is actually
equal to 2 lambda over D.
And this pattern continues.
And, of course,
because of the symmetry
we observe in this
expression, everything
is actually proportional
to sine squared something.
Therefore, this distribution
is actually symmetric.
So you have minus lambda over
D, minus 2 lambda over D,
et cetera, et cetera.
Any questions so far?
So what you can see here is
something really interesting.
Sine theta, if you
multiply that by r,
is telling you
the position which
you will see on the screen.
So this is actually--
if you are interested in some
place, point of interest P,
and this actually just
r times sine theta.
And this is actually the slit.
And I will move this
thing closer here.
And the size of this
slit is called D.
So one thing which is actually
very interesting in this result
is that, if we look at the
width of the central principal
maxima.
The width is
actually the measure
between the center
and the first minima,
where you have complete
destructive interference.
What you actually see here is
that this is actually something
very interesting is happening.
When you increase
D, if you increase
D, what is going to
happen to the position
of the first principal
minima, of our first minima?
It's going to what?
Going to become smaller.
Right?
So suppose I have a gap here and
I'm shooting a gun like crazy,
boo-boo-boo-boo boo-boo-boo-boo.
And I produce huge amount
of bullet, which I don't
recommend to do that, for sure.
What I'm going to do,
what I'm going to get
is a distribution like this,
which are the bullets passing
through this wall.
If I increase the
size of the wall,
the distribution I'm
getting is becoming what?
Wider.
Right?
But the result here is
actually surprising.
Why?
When you increase
the width, when
you increase the width of the D,
this function becomes smaller.
That means the central
maxima will become narrower,
as you can see from
this demonstration.
So the left-hand side is an
experimental setup which you
have a very, very narrow slit.
And basically you get a
very wide distribution
in the intensity as a function
of position on the screen.
Right-hand side is
another situation where
you have wider distribution.
I'm sorry, wider
slit, and you are
going to get a narrower
central maxima.
Which is actually different
from the other experiment
which we were actually doing.
So that's the first thing
which we learn from here.
And, also, the
distance, the distance
between the maxima
and the minima
is proportional to wavelength.
So that means I can
measure wavelength
by using the position
of the minima.
And we are going to do that
to measure the wavelength
of the laser beam.
And, finally, the last
thing which we learn
is that, in the central region,
you have a maxima of I0,
and this intensity is
going to be going down,
proportional to 1 over beta
squared, where beta is actually
defined here.
It's proportional
to D sine theta
and inversely proportional
to wavelength.
So now what I'm going
to do is experiment
which I would like
to measure what would
be the wavelength of my laser.
So I have a laser here.
Oh.
OK, I don't want
to hurt anybody.
So I have a laser here.
And I have a slit, which you
cannot see, unfortunately.
And I can read off the
width of the slit for you.
The width of the
slit is carefully
designed to be really
small, is 0.16 millimeter.
This is my width.
The D is actually equal
to 0.16 millimeter.
And on the screen, you can see
that there's a pattern formed
here, which you probably
cannot see very, very clearly,
so I will try to lower the
intensity of the other source.
So you can see,
then, see that there
is an interference pattern
or diffraction pattern which
is actually showing here.
So what I really need in order
to calculate the wavelength
is the sine theta angle.
Which I will really need
the sine theta angle.
Then I can actually
calculate what
will be the wavelength
of this laser.
So that means I will need
help from a volunteer.
Who volunteer to
help me to measure
the distance between this
slit and the large screen?
Can somebody volunteer?
Yes, please.
So we are going to
measure the distance.
Can you hold this?
And can you actually put it?
OK, try to pull this thing,
and we will try our best
to make it straight.
Thank you very much.
We don't want to destroy
the experiment as well.
This is not working?
Let me do this in the other way.
So how about-- trial
and error, right?
How about this.
You hold that thing, and I'm
going to actually measure
the distance from here.
And I need to really make it
really carefully, measure this
very carefully.
And I don't want to
destroy anything,
which is very possible.
So what I'm getting?
I get 7.5 meter.
So that's actually the distance
between the screen, the screen
and the source.
Hold that for a second.
I am going to measure the width
of, the distance between two
minima.
The distance between two
minima is 7 centimeter.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your help.
So we have now
everything we need
to calculate the wavelength.
I'm going to clean
this up first.
We have what?
We have the distance now.
The distance between the source
and the screen is 7.6 meter.
So now I would like to calculate
what will be the lambda.
And also I know the distance--
the distance between these
two minima is 7 centimeter.
So that means this
will be 3.5 centimeter.
So lambda divided by D is
actually equal to sine theta.
Which is actually small
d, which is the distance
between the minima.
The small d is here.
The small d is the
distance between the minima
and the center.
Divided by r, which is the
distance between the source
and the screen.
Therefore, I can
have lambda will
be equal to capital D
times small d divided by r.
So what is actually the answer?
So basically I have
capital D, which
is actually 0.16 millimeter.
So that is actually shown
there but you cannot see it.
So I will use a different
board for this calculation.
So, basically, we
will actually get
lambda is equal to capital D
times small d divided by r.
Capital D is 0.16 times
10 to the minus 3 meter.
And what is actually
the small d?
The small d is actually
3.5 centimeters.
And, finally, I have 7.6 meter,
which is actually the small r.
Divided by 7.6 meter.
Can somebody actually
calculate this for me?
Anybody have a smartphone?
This means that I haven't
done this experiment myself,
and we will see what
is going to happen.
I hope it will work.
What is actually the value?
AUDIENCE: 7.368 times
10 to the negative 7.
PROFESSOR: 7.368 times
10 to the minus 7.
This is actually equal
to 7.37 times 10--
oh, wait.
This is actually 737 nanometer.
Actually, the
wavelength of the red
is actually between 620 and 750.
And actually we are actually
getting the correct value.
You see?
So, actually, now you can
actually tell your friends
that, although the
wavelength is so small,
but I can't measure it
with such a square feet
experimental setup.
So that's a
successful experiment.
So that is actually
telling you that it's
a proof that this
formula, which we actually
do all the crazy
work of this Fourier
transform in
two-dimensional integration,
it should really work.
And the result is actually
not really far from what
you can get from Wikipedia.
So, at this point, I would like
to take a five-minute break
to take some questions.
And then we are going
to come back in, at 31,
and we are going to discuss
another very interesting issue,
resolution.
So welcome back.
So there are a few
questions about--
there were a few questions
about the pattern here,
which is interesting.
So you can see that what we
actually concluded from here
is that the width of the
central principal maxima
is actually two times of the
width of the secondary maxima.
So you can see that the width
here between these two points
is actually lambda over D. But
the width between these two
points, which actually
give you the width
of the central principal
maxima, is actually 2 times
of lambda over D.
And now this actually can be
seen from the experiment there.
Maybe not easy for the moment.
But this is actually the width,
and the smaller structure
is actually having a width
half of the central peak.
So that is actually something
which is interesting,
and I would like to share
that with everybody.
So now we actually come back
to the original question
we were actually
discussing last time.
So one interesting
thing we observed
in this two-slit
interference experiment
is that you not only see all
those little structures, which
is actually kind of
periodic structure,
and that they are coming from
the two-slit interference.
And you also see
this larger structure
which is showing up there, which
is actually going up and down,
and also it produce minima
at some specific point.
Now we understand what
is actually happening.
Suppose I have two-slit
interference experiment, where
I have the width of the slits to
be capital D, to be very small.
D is very, very small.
And the distance
between the slit
is actually called small d.
Which is kind of
weird, but you have
to accept that because
it's on my note.
And you can see
that, interestingly,
if this is the situation, then
you have this periodic pattern
and you will see no
decrease in amplitude
as a function of distance with
respect to the central point
of the screen.
So that's actually very nice.
However, if you consider
a realistic situation,
where the size, or say the width
of the slit is not negligible,
is sizable.
And what is going
to happen is that--
OK, let's forget about the
second one for a moment.
We already learned that
the output intensity
of a single slit is already
varying as a function of angle.
So I have this pattern.
Therefore, if you have these
two realistic slit interacting
with each other, have
interference pattern,
what you are going to
expect is that you are going
to have the two-slit
interference pattern modulated
by diffraction pattern.
Because, originally,
coming from a single slit,
you already have a
varying intensity
as a function of sine theta,
as we already discussed there.
So, if we put all those
information together,
we are going to get I.
The intensity is going
to be equal to I0, which is
some maxima, sine beta divided
by beta, square of that,
sine N delta divided by 2,
divided by sine delta
divided by 2, squared.
So basically what
I'm talking about
is that, if you have
N-slit experiment,
each slit have the same width.
And what you are
going to get is--
this is actually the N-slit
interference pattern.
And that is actually modulated
by diffraction pattern.
Where beta, just a
reminder, in this summary
is pi capital D divided
by lambda sine theta.
And the delta, which is
the optical path length
difference we defined before,
is k times d sine theta,
and that is actually equal
to 2 pi times d sine theta
divided by lambda.
So that is actually
why, when we perform
the experiment of a double-slit
experiment in the last lecture,
we get complicated
interference pattern like this,
and it has a very
complicated structure.
And now we actually understand
why the structure is like this.
The small structure in
this case is actually
coming from interference,
two-slit interference.
And the additional structure,
larger-scale structure,
is actually coming
from diffraction,
is coming from the varying
intensity of a single slit
as a function of sine theta.
Any questions so far?
We are making a lot of progress.
So what I would
like to move on is
to discuss with you
something really interesting.
So we discussed and learned how
to explain why we have actually
colorful soap bubble.
So I have something
totally unrelated.
So we have a soap bubble
also in the space, which
is the Soap Bubble nebula.
Which is really interesting,
and you can actually
Google it and see what is
actually happening there.
But, actually, that's
actually not my point.
Then my point is that you
really need very good resolution
telescope so that you can
actually observe those really
beautiful objects which are
already there and cannot be
made by human.
Made by somebody else.
So this is actually
what I'm getting into.
So the resolution is
really something important.
So when you take a
look at this picture,
the resolution is not very good.
So as you can see, now the peak
position of two nearby peak
is actually connecting
to each other.
Then what do we see
from this picture?
You see maybe a lion?
I don't know.
Maybe, maybe not.
But if you improve the
resolution, what do you see?
It's actually zebra.
So this is actually
the kind of thing
which we would like
to discuss with you.
We are actually touching
this important phenomenon,
which is actually
needed for observing
an interesting phenomena which
is actually happening really
far away from the Earth.
What is actually the resolution?
And we are going to
talk about that as well.
And I would like to show you
another interesting example.
So this is a comparison
between not so serious picture
and the picture from
Hubble telescope.
So I was using some telescope
with D equal to 40 centimeter.
And that's actually
the best thing
which I can achieve, shooting
the same planetary nebula M57.
That object is actually
2,500 light year away.
And you can see that I cannot
get really a lot of detail from
this image.
And now, if you
compare that to D equal
to 240 centimeter
Hubble telescope,
and also, at the
same time, this thing
is actually above
the atmosphere.
So that's actually
very, very important.
And you can see that you do get
a much, much better resolution,
and you can actually see all
the fine detail, very, very
fine detail of this image.
And we are in the
position to understand
the resolution and the
limit which we can have
due to diffraction, actually.
So if I consider now a
pinhole with diameter equal
to D. So right now what
we are actually doing
is not a single slit any
more, but a hole with radius
D over 2.
And we can do the same,
exactly the same calculation
using this formula.
But I'm not going to do
that for the sake of time.
So we can do exactly that
same C function calculation.
And what we are going to get
is I as a function of theta
is equal to I0 J1 beta
divided by beta, squared.
Where J1 is the Bessel
function of the first kind.
Sounds really scary,
but it's actually not.
So what I really need is the
zeros of the Bessel function,
so that I can actually
extract the interference
pattern and the width
of the central maximum.
So now, since we are
having a pinhole,
basically all of
those things are,
all those patterns are
actually two-dimensional.
And I was wondering what will be
the needed beta value so that I
can actually reach the minima.
Why is that important?
That is actually
telling you the limit
of the optical resolution.
If I have two peaks
which are actually
placed too close to each
other, like what we actually
see in the previous
slide, then we
can actually not separate very
well these two light source.
On the other hand, if the
distance between these two peak
is larger than the
first minima, then I
can actually be very safe.
I can actually separate.
I can say that, ha, this
is really two peaks.
Two stars, two light source.
I can tell.
So that is actually why
this is actually important.
And where is
actually the minima?
And I can already
solve that for you.
And that is actually when
x is equal to roughly,
the numerical value
is roughly 3.83.
So that's actually
not important.
Those numbers are not important.
The important result is
really the conclusion.
So beta is equal to 3.83,
and that is actually
equal to pi D sine
theta divided by lambda.
So that is actually our
original definition.
And I can solve what will be the
sine theta, which is actually
telling you the
position of the minima.
So sine theta will be equal to
actually 1.22 lambda divided
by D.
So what does that mean?
That means the position where
you have the first minima
is actually happening
when you have sine theta--
this is the theta--
when you have sine theta equal
to 1.22 times lambda divided
by D.
So that is actually very nice.
Doing exactly the same
exercise, and we now
understand where my minima is.
Then that is
actually telling you
something about the resolution.
So what I'm going
to try to get into
is that, now, let's design a
phone together, a mobile phone
together.
So what is actually the
width of the human pupil?
The width is actually
roughly 2 to 4 millimeter--
when narrow, when you see a lot
of light all over the place--
or 3 to 8 millimeter.
So that is actually the
typical length when wide.
width of the pinhole.
So, typically, the visible
light, as we calculated,
is something like 500 nanometer.
And the width of
the human pupil, we
can actually take a
number of 5 millimeter.
And now we can actually try to
give input to the phone design.
So what will be the resolution
if we take these two
parameter together?
So, basically, the
resolution of your eye, we
can now calculate that.
So what is that?
That is actually 1.22 times
500 nanometer divided by--
OK, my function is D--
so divided by D is
equal to 5 millimeter.
5 millimeter.
Basically, what you
are going to get
is 1.22 times 10 to the minus 4.
This is actually the resolution.
Sine theta, roughly
equal to theta,
is actually equal to 1.22
times 10 to the minus 4.
I have a iPhone 6 or
7, whatever you have.
Basically is 401 ppi.
401 ppi is actually
what is that?
Pixel per inch.
So what is actually the delta x?
So if I have a phone, OK,
it has a camera there.
That is my phone.
And this is my eye.
Looks like an eye.
The distance is 20 centimeter.
I do this, which is unusual.
We have 400 ppi.
So what is actually the delta x,
the delta x between the pixels?
The delta x is equal to 2.54
centimeter divided by 401,
and that will give you
something like 6.3 times 10
to the minus 3 centimeter.
If I am trying to be
healthy and I do this, then
what is actually
the delta theta?
The delta theta is delta x
divided by 20 centimeter,
and that is 3 times
10 to be minus 4.
If you compare this
value to the limit
I calculated here, you can see
that, what is the conclusion?
Can I resolve the
pixels on the phone?
The answer is yes.
So that means this phone
is not good enough.
They have to do more work.
And now I'm going
to design a jPhone.
Maybe at some point
I got really crazy
and I decided to
open a company, which
is Yen-Jie's phone company.
And, of course, I will say this
is jPhone because it's Yen-Jie.
And I'm going to put
40,000 ppi in this phone.
Will you buy it?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: How much?
PROFESSOR: $1.
You'll buy it?
We'll see.
Maybe you will buy it
because you are my student.
But it's not worth it.
Why is that?
Because you cannot resolve this
kind of fine or small distance
between pixels.
So it's actually useless.
So what is actually the limit?
You can also probably
give that to your friends.
2,000 pixel per inch
is roughly the limit.
Beyond that, maybe the next
generation of our students
will be using this like this.
Then it works, and
it is worth it.
You can actually
read this distance.
It doesn't work for old people
like me, but for young people
it works.
So very good.
So that's another thing
which you have learned.
So, finally, as I
promised you, we
are going to go back to
this business of designing
the Enterprise for Star Trek.
So what does Enterprise
do to their friends?
They shoot laser beam.
And they try to attack
the other ships.
And what I'm going to do
now is to calculate for you
what is going to happen.
OK, now I have this
laser beam here.
And, in principle,
before you take 8.03,
you are going to say,
aha, I can shoot the moon.
And this light is going
to be really narrow
and it's going to hit the moon,
a very small area on the moon.
Do you believe that now?
I hope the answer is not.
How crazy is this idea?
What is the size of the spot?
Can you guess?
Is that 1 millimeter?
10 meter?
Or 200 kilometer?
How many of you think
by now is 1 millimeter?
Nobody?
Fortunately.
How about 10 meter?
One, two, three.
OK.
Three of you.
How about 200 kilometer?
You believe that?
Really?
The answer is really
200 kilometer.
It's the size of Missouri state.
So now you can see that this
is not practical at all,
and you have to really do what?
Increase or decrease the radius?
AUDIENCE: Increase.
PROFESSOR: Increase.
By the end of this lecture
everybody get this idea.
Thank you very much
for the attention.
And I hope you
enjoyed this lecture.